be clear in your mind in what you intend
to achieve know what you are going to do
that doesn't seem like too much to ask
certainly in war and you wouldn't think
it would be too much for people to ask
in their lives either their precious
lives as precious as these 58,000 that
died in Vietnam heroes but how often do
we see people going through their lives
without knowing what they are trying to
do without having any intent without
having a clear mission I'm talking on an
individual level as a person people go
through their lives without knowing what
it is they want to do what they want to
accomplish
so know what your mission is know what
your intent as the commander of your
life
know what your intent is and then fight
with everything you've got to win
and I think that's all I've got for
tonight so let go
maybe if you want to shed some light on
how people can maybe help themselves win
that war sure and maybe support the
podcast if they want to they want to
yeah that point though in my opinion is
it good it's a good one it's a good one
think about you people go through their
lives they don't know what they're
trying to do yeah and it sounds the same
thing as going to war without knowing
what the outcome is supposed to be yeah
your goal but it sounds kind of like
obvious when you say it you know like
hey go through you know when you go
through life should you have a goal real
obvious yes
you're not gonna say no you shouldn't
have a goal kind of thing so it seems
obvious but you know how you live day to
day you you know you might have a goal
for the day maybe two maybe three but
Brett life is full life is a full
spectrum of stuff well get it's so
shocking because what you're saying is
absolutely true you wouldn't think that
people would be going through life
without knowing where they're trying to
get to yeah but you wouldn't think that
a nation would go to war without clear
intention of where they want to end up
and how they're gonna get there and
least and I really how you gonna get
there now I have a little bit of like
when clouds Fitz says how you're gonna
conduct the war that's not necessarily
true cuz you don't know you can't know
how you're gonna conduct a war before
the war starts you can have an idea but
you can't know fully just like if you
were to say hey my goal is to X in my
life you don't know how you're gonna be
able to do that yeah cuz you talking
about cuz you gonna just you're gonna
make it adaptations things are gonna
come up things are gonna change the
battlefield changes your life changes
things pop up mean things happen so I
think that that idea that you're gonna
know how you're gonna execute something
is is far-fetched I think you well
actually I should use the word idea you
should have an idea of how you're gonna
do it yeah you should have an idea like
okay well this is what I need to get
done this is what I want to achieve in
my life yeah I want to make I want to do
this
mmm-hmm what's a simple one I want to
own a house that's a simple one that's a
good place to start yeah I want to own a
house okay
well let's think about how we're gonna
get there you know that's let's let's
think about how we're gonna get there
you have to build your credit you have
to how do you build your credit you have
to you have to borrow money some people
something they go to buy a house they've
never borrowed money before you can't
borrow money if you've never borrowed
money you can't borrow money for a house
if you've never borrowed money for a car
or a or some smaller object before so
you gotta establish your credit then you
gotta have two years worth of income
then you gotta have a big fat
downpayment sitting ready so there's
things you got to do this thing good now
now that might change the clock along
the way the idea is that you got to move
towards that goal that's what was so
nice about hearing the Vietnamese
commander's intent get close split them
up yeah boom you go make that happen
hey guess what you want to buy a house
one day save money have good credit yeah
okay well you got to make money how you
gonna make money you might make it
driving uber you might make it
delivering pizza you might make it you
got your real job do that support in
your family but then you need a little
extra to throw in there well that's why
you end up driving uber or you end up or
whatever it is you're gonna do you wanna
make your some money on the side that
you can start stashing away yeah yeah
and at the end of the day you do have
that goal you know so it is yeah how you
conduct yourself it's not gonna be cut
and dry for sure but you know in these
examples like you know you want to buy a
house that's a goal that's a specific
goal but that's just one teeny tiny goal
in life if you're of course and you're
not gonna run into somebody who their
only goal in life is to buy a house some
people don't buy a house it's stupid you
should rent them that's fine yeah I'm
not telling everyone what their goal
should be and if you want to keep
renting keep renting maybe that's for
you yeah yeah fully not for me yeah
nobody's for you there's other things
you want to put your money that's cool
you're doing some other something else
smart with your money yeah that's fine
yeah like like buying rims or something
like that
either way though if you uh consider
like just what went positive closer to
tightening what what are you saying in
compared to life right we're buying
house sure that's one of many goals you
can have in life because life is full
like not it but so it kind of when you
really think about it bright it's hard
it's hard to like designate some
specific goals and then that's all
you're gonna do okay let's say you're
gonna you're gonna say you're gonna be
financially secure and independent okay
that would be a much bigger loss yeah
that's an awesome goal behalf and the
younger you make that goal but better
chance you have of achieving it yeah
because now you're not wasting your
money you're actually saving for house
so you can get that house paid off so
now you don't have a mortgage anywhere
you know he's like yeah that's a bigger
goal that's a broader goal just like
when you when you go to war you need to
know what it is you're going to war for
what are you gonna do and when you're
gonna stop and what's your intended
result yeah so you gotta in a way you
got to fill your life with a bunch of
goals so you don't get Jim because you
have small goals that lead to the big
goal right so for instance you want to
be financially secure and stable what
are you gonna do you're gonna save some
of your money okay that's one thing
you're gonna buy a house that's another
thing you're gonna pay off your car and
you're not gonna buy expensive dumb cars
you're gonna buy cheap cars until you
have the money to buy him with cash
you're gonna make all these little
things you're gonna work extra you're
gonna you know you're gonna do these
things so you're right you have you have
your broad goal yes you have your
long-term goal yes and then you got your
short-term goals that lead and are
strategically aligned with that
long-term goal it's the same thing in
war you have to have those both those
things going